en france l'événement culturel de ce 1er
janvier avec la réouverture de beaubourg
une rénovation entamée il ya plus de
deux ans réaménagement et réhabilitation
technique
un immense chantier qui s'achève ouvert
gratuitement au public cette femme
semaines avant l'inauguration par
jacques chirac lance janvier prochain
daniel wolfromm diane richard certains
attendent depuis 7 heures du matin pour
avoir ce privilège d'être les premiers à
pénétrer dans le centre profite tout
retaper de fond en comble la ministre de
la culture et la direction du centre
récompense les deux valeureux visiteurs
le béton remplace la moquette dans le
hall d'accueil où la signalisation est
plus coloré plus vigoureux sous l'oeil
du fondateur
pourquoi ce que vous avez pu naître la
première pour lever dire de démarrer une
année de lui
quelle est votre première impression
c'est super la bibliothèque publique à
son propre accès menant elle a pris la
place de l'administration du centre
parti le jir ailleurs résultats 2000
places de lecture et une vue imprenable
sur le quartier pour la visite
mais on pourra y travailler qu'à partir
du 26 janvier le musée d'art moderne et
les expositions temporaires occupent les
deux derniers niveaux un gain de place
pour 600 oeuvres exposées en plus elles
sont que l'aménagement et c'est un petit
peu classique il a perdu en modernité
mais il a sans doute gagné en confort
visuel
ben je viens d'arriver mais la première
impression
oui c'est très bien c'est très bien
enfin les escalators extérieur la
fameuse chauny on ne pourra plus
l'emprunter gratuitement il faudra
désormais payer pour visiter les
terrasses